[Music]
hello everyone fabulous my name is
Victor Tehran I am an Android
accessibility Technical Program Manager
and we're super happy that you decided
to spend the next 40 minutes of your
time at this conference with us learning
about accessibility and about related
work we do at Google so thank you for
that and that's cool
so why we're here today in this session
we would like to showcase how access to
surrounding environment information and
technology can empower people with
disabilities to be productive and
independent in their lives according to
World Health Organization there is over
1 billion people with disabilities in
the world it's 9 zeros 150 million of
these people have difficulty performing
even the most basic of daily tasks for
example some of us take for granted
picking up a glass of water or walking
out of the house to your favorite
restaurant or listening to a video on
YouTube or finding something in a low
lighting conditions for other people
these tasks aren't so easily achievable
technology has an amazing power to
change that in fact if you think about
it for millennia Humanity has been
developing low and high tech gadgets
I'll give you a few examples we'll sorry
no Nobel Prize for this one but fire
clock typewriter smartphone all of these
things we have been creating so that we
can improve the quality of our lives for
some people this is just improve the
quality of their lives yet for others
like for people with disabilities
the
gadgets these new technical advancements
made it possible in many cases unable to
live their lives
I for example being completely blind
could not do my work at Google without
assistive technology or computers or
other tools that helped me to do very
basic things in my life you know paying
bills taxes what-have-you so in this
case again technology is just super
important and today we would like to
talk to you about some of that
technology now some of you probably in
the audience have experienced low-light
conditions where you were trying to find
something or how about a shaky train
where you were trying to read something
the book that you've been waiting for so
long to pick up and read many things
right you might remember discomfort and
frustration that you find yourself
grappling with when find inside yourself
in such circumstances you probably
wouldn't want discomfort and frustration
to be companion for the rest of your
life but unfortunately for many people
with disabilities it is they have to
live with this now technology as I
mentioned before has an amazing power to
change if not all of that then certainly
a lot of these things we at Google
actually create some of that technology
I think we know something about
technology at Google right we create
their technology and since we created
technology we feel like we have you here
for that purpose so we can tell you
about things we create over the last
year we've been working hard on creating
some of the new tools to help people
with disabilities but also create new
api's and frameworks to help developers
like you to create more accessible apps
and more inclusive products with that I
would like to invite Brian to talk to
you to kick off our marathon and to talk
to you
well where's Brian I'm right here oh
you're here
alright years it goes Brian welcome
Brian Thank You Victor thank you
everybody
my name is Brian Kemmler and I'm a
product manager on Android accessibility
I'm excited to discuss our new
accessibility services and the api's
that make them possible now let's dive
in and discuss how we're innovating in
this space first I'm gonna talk about
what we're doing in Android P to make
hearing conversations a little easier
listening is difficult even in a quiet
field with no background noise and a
large set of ears but the everyday
reality is we live work and play with an
increasing amount of environmental noise
in fact unwanted sound is one of the
most common environmental problems it's
not only annoying but it prevents us
from understanding our colleagues
friends and loved ones no matter how
well we can hear most of us can relate
to the following acoustically
challenging situations listening to your
dinner date in a loud restaurant trying
to listen to a caller in a loud airport
lounge listening to a presenter who is
speaking too softly like me right now
one could think about environmental
noise as a form of situational
disability but what if you could turn
down the noise and boost the signal on
your smartphone so you would never miss
the conversation now you can because
today we're introducing sound amplifier
sound amplifier is a new accessibility
service that helps users focus on real
world conversations using only an
Android smartphone and a set of
headphones
users can too users can tune hundreds of
personalized levels to optimize their
listening experience to the current
environment its two sliders for loudness
and tuning dynamically adjust over 100
audio presets in the background the
settings can then be independently
applied to each ear adjusting them
provides ambient sound improves ambient
sound quality in a vast array of
scenarios including enhancing sound and
loud distant or faraway spaces
increasing the volume of somebody who
speaks softly tuning turning up the TV
to a volume that's understandable and
acceptable for everybody in the room now
I'm going to briefly explain how it was
built using the new dynamics processing
effect sound amplifier was built on the
new dynamics processing effect in
androids audio framework the effect is
based on a four stage signal processing
architecture Stage one is pre
equalization you can think about the pre
equalizer as a programmatic way to
adjust any audio frequency think base to
travel and everything in between stage
two is a multiband compressor the
multiband compressor is the keystone of
the dynamic processing effect it adjusts
up soft sounds and adjust down loud
sounds to provide a much better
listening experience Stage three is post
Equalization similar to the first stage
it allows you to fine-tune any audio
frequency
lastly Stage four the limiter prevents
additional gain above a developer
designated threat threshold which
prevents loud or unwanted noises we're
going to be doing a number of demos and
a deep dive on the dynamics processing
effect and sound amplifier
Thursday at 3:30 on Stage five so please
join us there if you want to learn more
switching topics I'm going to discuss
what we're doing to make Android easier
for users with mobility and dexterity
challenges for example we're gonna do a
little empathy exercise so first I'm
gonna ask everybody to take out their
phones alright now I want everybody to
take a screenshot this does have a
purpose take a screenshot please after
you've done that I want you to do it
again
but I want you to do it with just one
hand
screenshot screenshot on your phone not
quite as easy is it with one hand on for
tens of millions of users this is their
everyday reality these might be users
with tremors or limited hand strength
for them simple tasks such as holding
the phone
pressing hardware buttons or performing
gestures can be difficult painful and
time-consuming accessibility service
accessibility menu is a new
accessibility service to make common
interactions easier for users with
physical disabilities in the US alone
this is a population of over 75 million
users accessibility menu simplifies the
following functions hard work shortcuts
including power off lock screen take
screenshot and volume control gestures
like swipe up and swipe down for recent
apps notifications and quick settings
it'll also allow you to invoke the
assistant or go directly to
accessibility settings instantly further
we designed it with very large touch
targets located at the bottom of the
screen this facilitates reach ability
for those with smaller hands or limited
reach it works in both portrait
and landscape mode lastly accessibility
menu is built on top of our
accessibility framework we added two new
api's for screenshot and lockscreen so
developers can start using it today so
now I'm gonna pass the baton over to
Patrick to talk a little bit about
vision well thanks Brian all right hello
everyone my name is Patrick Clary I'm a
product manager on accessibility at
Google and I'm very excited today to
announce for the very first time here at
i/o a new app coming to the play store
called Lookout so lookout is a new app
for users who are blind and low-vision
and it'll be used for useful for them in
certain situations where they require
help from others so for example one of
these users might be entering a new
space for the first time right they
might not know if other people are
present in that space they might need
assistance for example if I need a chair
or reading the office directory another
example is when a user is cooking they
might need assistance reading a recipe
or locating different ingredients so the
goal of lookout is to leverage a user
smartphone to make these physical spaces
and others more accessible to these
users who are blind or vision
impairments you can think of Lookout as
a personal guide that sees the world and
speaks items of importance that it
detects in the environment so when a
user downloads Lookout and opens the app
this is what they'll see they'll see a
mode selection where they can pick
between four different modes and not
launch will salute will support work and
play home scanning which is for scanning
long-form text and experimental these
allow users to actually specify the
activity they're partaking in and
fine-tunes lookout to provide more
relevant results so after selecting the
mode
user will be presented with a live view
which will speak items of importance as
they're detected next I'd like to roll
just a short video that profiles one of
our testers who's an artist up in San
Francisco and describes the impact that
an app like this can have my first
experience with the labyrinth was this
amazing piece of canvas art that were
being allowed to walk on kind of in this
swirling choreography I was so excited
to experience this new thing my name is
Maya Scott I am a theater and art
instructor I was born visually impaired
I kind of see like an impressionist
painting I'm often scooching around
working with my supplies and they don't
always end up where I want them to be
and I can't find the scissors
[Music]
both as an artist and a teacher building
a labyrinth was the next step for me to
invite people to have a physical
experience with art and not just observe
it very much in our lives were invited
to watch or listen instead of witnessing
or doing
[Music]
so that gives you a little idea of the
type of experience that look-out can
provide so when we were building lookout
we focused on what we call a passive
experience and we imagine users using it
by wearing their Android device and a
lanyard like this or perhaps in a shirt
pocket now this is a big objective of
ours this passive experience we don't
want to force the user to interrupt the
activity they're engaging with for
example if the user is cooking they can
remain engaged in that activity without
having to take out their device and
interact with the screen so while
wearing the phone look help provides
these useful hints about what the user
is holding in front of them and to
facilitate this we've designed a set of
external controls so as you may have
noticed in the video a user can actually
knock on the device to begin recognition
this live recognition that lookout
provides and they can do other things
like cover the camera to pause
recognition or use the fingerprint
sensor to change different modes so let
me tell you a little bit about how this
works
so first lookout will collect live
imagery of the scene around the user and
then we'll run a series of machine
learning recognizers to detect things
like bar codes detective people or
present detect objects and read text in
the scene the next thing we do is score
these items first on based on a
personalization model and the mode that
the user has chosen this way we only
speak the relevant and important items
to the user this is important because as
you can imagine and a standard scene
there could be many things so we want to
we can detect however we only want to
tell the user about the important things
based on what we know about the context
that they're currently in it's important
to note that we do most of this all on
the device so that latency is low and
you can actually use this app completely
without an internet connection
so that's Lookout an app for users who
are blind and low-vision that harnesses
the power of machine learning to provide
relevant results about physical spaces
around them it's coming to the Play
Store for users in the US on pixel
devices very soon this summer and we're
also start rolling out to trusted
testers so if you'd like to test this
app go to google.com slash accessibility
and sign up to be a trusted tester you
can come to our sandbox to see a demo as
well so next I'll hand it over to Maya
who'll talk about what we're doing in
the cognitive space Thank You Patrick
hi I'm Maya Benari and I'm a product
manager on android framework a year ago
we launched a service called select to
speak Target accuser we difficulties
operating selectors big allows user to
select and on the screen and the text
will be read aloud today we're happy to
announce that we added OCR capability to
select to speak in camera and picture
this makes text even more accessible
user can simply select text using the
camera or in the picture and the text
will be highlighted and read aloud now I
want to show you a brief demo for that
I'm actually going to go off the stage
I'm going to open my camera can my
camera be shown here you go so this is
the like this is the live cameras view
and this is the regular camera and I
have here the accessibility button
I have your accessibility button here in
the corner I'm going to turn it on and
next I'm going to select the text select
to speak with OCR is available in
Android P beta today please try it out
Thank You clicker so it's available in
Android P beta today it's going to come
soon to the general beta we'd love to
have your feedback now I'm going to talk
a bit about android framework and our
goal in the Android accessibility
framework is to help get rid of the
assumptions that device are built on for
example not all user can interact with
the touchscreen or with the standard UI
or even hear the sounds that the device
is producing now we're supporting this
goal in two ways the first one is we're
developing api's for apps and services
to make it easier to support wide range
of audience and second we are
implementing accessibility features into
the framework now I will talk about
three new API edition to enable to the
developers to make their app more
accessible and the first one is add a
pane title so first let me start is what
is a pane a pen is a section of the
window that is visually distinct for
user with which is visually distinct for
user and change it like a window changes
an example of the pain you can see here
in the quick setting and the
notification shade prior to Android Beam
accessibility services could not easily
determine when paints on the screen has
been updated in Android Beam we added an
attribute called accessibility pane
title no accessibility services are
automatically notified to changes to the
pane so user get more granular
information about what has changed with
minimal input from app developer so
please do add a title to your pain the
second IPL is called an accessibility
heading this is an attribute so
developer can mark whether something is
the heading inside their app and this is
intended for apps with text-heavy views
this will allow talkback user who cannot
see the screen to navigate more
efficiently between different heading
inside their art without first listening
to the whole text and the last API is we
add the ability we basically the last
leg VI is for setting what is focused
ball and that API is designed to control
the grouping of the contract of that
content for example let's say that you
have a sports course and you want to
ensure that the number goes with the
team instead of topic reading all the
teams and then all the numbers which can
be very confusing for the users who
cannot see the screen now you can use
screen reader focusable to improve how
screen readers group the content and by
the way we're also updating our
documentation for accessibility focus
and grouping so please check it out the
accessibility section in
developer.android.com now I'm going to
talk about three new additional features
coming to the end
framework the first one is a just
vibration this is a new setting for
users with 30 eg issues to adjust the
ring and notification vibration and also
the touch sensitivity the second the
second setting is called remove
animation as some user find animation
distracting so we basically just added a
new setting to turn those off and Russ
and the last and the last features is a
year ago we launched the volume key
accessibility shortcut so basically to
toggle on and off accessibility certain
accessibility services you need to long
press for three seconds the volume keys
now we did two changes to that one based
on the feedback the first one we add a
new settings that you can toggle on and
off which is color correction and color
inversion and the second one is we
reduced the time to activate from three
seconds to one second after the initial
activation
[Applause]
in the next section I'm going to talk
about testing for accessibility and its
importance for everything that we build
into the OS we see the power of the
accessibility services in the app
ecosystem and we want that ecosystem to
be as accessible as possible now there
are multiple ways to test including
manual testing and automated testing in
general we found the combination of both
could provide you a better coverage for
your app next I'm going to cover
different testing tools and how those
can be integrated to cover to cover
accessibility to discover accessibility
issues first let me talk a little bit
about manual testing and this is the
most reliable way to understand how your
product are used by different users with
disabilities what you need there is you
need to turn on to talkback or switch
access with your app because you want to
be in the shoes of the user to feel how
it is to run an accessibility service
however we are aware that manual testing
takes time and you cannot test for every
change that you make into the app and
for that we also provide there is also
automated testing we develop Android
accessibility testing framework also
shortly called
ATF to quickly identify common
accessibility issues early in the
development cycle ATF is an open source
library which we already integrated into
espresso and Robo electric testing
framework so you can leverage your
existing tests to identify accessibility
issues atf 3.0 3.0 is now available on
Geetha next we have two automated tools
that integrate accessibility testing
framework play pre-launch report
accessibility scanner in play
pre-launch report we're making it even
easier to get accessibility tests
resolved by integrating those directly
into the developer console now first
what is play pre-launch report this is
an automated testing solution which
caused apps on multiple physical devices
and the text issues the developer can
fix before reaching their end users
including recognizing crashes and
performance issues the tool runs
automatically on all apk published to
the alpha and beta Channel now play free
laundry pole play pre-launch report also
include accessibility tests this is yet
another example how we integrate our
core accessibility testing library as
play pre-launch report crawls your app
as in this example this is cooking up in
each step it will launch accessibility
tests including contrast ratio touch
target size missing labels and so on and
the test result will be automatically
integrated into the test report this
will provide the developer and
opportunity to fix those two Vic those
before their app launches and make their
app more accessible lastly I'll mention
accessibility scanner which is an app
that suggests accessibility improvement
for Android apps
utilizing accessibility testing
framework and we're very happy that up
till today accessibility scanner
discovered more than three and a half
million opportunities for improving
accessibility in apps for improving
accessibility apps so big shout out for
accessibility scanner
a new version of accessibility scanner
is available today with additional
accessibility checks such as true
traversal order for screen reader and in
parental Ament type for accessibility we
also improved the UI for contrast
suggestion and finally we also are
allowing changes for threshold for
contrast ratio and touch target size so
to download accessibility scanner please
go to geo accessibility scanner to sum
up this section we talked about manual
testing and we showed a number of tools
to help automate testing but the most
successful projects incorporate both
manual testing and automated testing so
please do try out the different tools
and do develop a testing strategy for
accessibility for your app now another
vital piece of the puzzle is to
understand the user experience and your
user needs and with that said I will end
it off to Melissa to talk about user
research
Thank You Maya my name is Melissa bar
Navarre and I'm a user experience
researcher on Android so now that we've
gotten a sneak peek at the accessibility
features and services coming in Android
P I'd like to talk about the role of
user research in the design and
development process but first what
exactly is user research user research
focuses on understanding user behaviors
needs and motivations it is the process
of understanding the impact of design on
an audience so as technologists we may
think we know what's best for our users
but oftentimes we don't the user is
truly the expert in their experiences by
seeking to understand user behaviors
needs and motivations we start to
challenge our assumptions and reshape
our perspectives why do it why do we do
user research you may have heard the
stat that 9 out of 10 startups fail but
you may not know that the number one
reason for failure is lack of a market
need for a product so in those
situations people design and develop
products then look for an audience who
might be interested in using them user
research advocates for the opposite by
putting users first you can validate
your ideas and inform your products
direction hopefully you're thinking
great but when do I get started and the
short answer is now use user research
involves a set of practices that runs
along your existing product development
cycle helping you make decisions at each
stage so methods like field studies
interviews or competitive analysis can
help you explore a specific area of
technology and uncover opportunity areas
once you've decided what you want to
build and you have a prototype methods
like cognitive walkthroughs usability
tests or participatory design exercises
can help you make and
or in design decisions and once your
product is out in the market methods
like log analysis diary studies or
surveys can help you evaluate its
performance and if you don't have a lot
of time or experience that's okay just
take a few hours and talk to a few users
jakob nielsen of the Nielsen Norman
group found that the best results come
from small affordable studies with no
more than five users so now I'd like to
show you how Android uses user research
to improve our accessibility offerings
let's take the example of talkback
vibration feedback talkback the google
screenreader uses vibration feedback by
default we knew that some people turn
this off and we wanted to know why why
does some people turn it off while
others leave it on are there situations
where vibration is more or less useful
and as the pattern or intensity of the
vibration make a difference good
research starts with good research
questions because we were interested in
perceptions of vibration feedback we
started with user interviews we asked
screen reader users questions like do
you use vibration feedback why or why
not
have you ever turn it off when did you
turn it off and how would you describe
the intensity of vibration on your phone
is it too high too low or just right
after getting a sense of the
participants needs we prompted them to
compare vibration feedback across a
range of Android phones so these tasks
added a usability component to our study
an in this research we validated a real
need for vibration feedback we learned
that vibration provides valuable
navigational information to visually
impaired users especially in noisy
environments when they may not be able
to hear spoken feedback on their device
we also learned that the more distinct
the vibration pattern the more useful
finally we learned that users wanted the
ability to adjust vibration intensity
according to their personal preferences
so in Android P we're giving greater
control to the user over vibration
feedback anyone will be able to go to
their accessibility to accessibility
settings and increase decrease or
disable vibration and this is just the
beginning we will continue to make
improvements is in this area as we
further research so now we're gonna hand
it over to Victor for some final
announcements and resources to help you
going forward alright thanks Melissa for
highlighting the importance of user
research in the product decisions we
make super important as you have seen
already well next we couldn't just let
you go without a few more months
announcements could we first I'd like to
announce that voice access an
accessibility service that helps someone
with dexterity issues to use their
Android phone completely through their
voice just simply issuing Boykins
voice access is graduating from Veda
after months of user research
development iterations we are finally
ready to launch it and give it to you
coming soon this summer with new UI
enhancements a better assistant
integration and by assistant main Google
assistant just to be sure coming with
Google assistant UI and more improved
interaction overall so look out for
voice access the next thing I'd like to
let you know about is that we decided to
package a lot of our or our
accessibility services that you commonly
find built into an android device into a
single package we call Android
accessibility suite some of the services
include talkback
screenreader for people who are blind
and visually impaired switch access a
software that allows people the physical
impairments to use their device with
just a single button or a single switch
select to speak that my just demoed a
few minutes ago and accessibility menu
that Bryant also showcased earlier and
more to come we hope that with the new
Android accessibility suite other
accessibility services not just talk
back will be more discoverable in the
Play Store as well as this will become a
platform for new future accessibility
services we will be developing but
enough about us I think it's time to
talk about you a little bit right I
think you deserve guys you build a lot
of the cool stuff too
last evening we announced Google Play
Awards and I'm just would like to give a
shout out to a few amazing developers
that have been working on stuff or apps
to make our ecosystem better and more
accessible first our winner is be my
eyes be my eyes is a cross-platform
solution that connects people who need
help with people who are willing or
excited to give that help the way the
service works is that someone who is
blind or who needs help requests it by
declaring themselves as a person who
needs help and then people on the other
hand can sign up as volunteers and when
such help request comes they get a
notification then they pick it pick up
the video link and then they can help
somebody in real time so be my eyes
check it out on a play store the next
one I'd like to mention is the Open
Sesame
now Open Sesame is already unknown to
some people who have been with us during
various Google i/o events and otherwise
the coolness of Open Sesame
accessibility solution is that allows
people to control their Android device
by just looking at it
it's amazing so check out Open Sesame
and the link is on the screen the last
but not least I'd like to mention we
really really really care about game
because while it's an important aspect
of computing to be productive and
independent it's just as important to
have fun and so one of our yesterday
winners is a company from New Zealand
called audio game hub and what they've
created is an experience for anyone to
be able to play audio games with their
eyes closed so you only realize on your
ears and then you plays all kinds of
funky games you know I'm not gonna name
those games I hope you'll go to the Play
Store and check them out for yourself
and I'd like to leave you with a few
resources we already mentioned
accessibility scanner please download it
test with accessibility scanner the
website where you can find all of the
best accessibility practices for Android
development G dot 0 slash Android
accessibility and of course user
research and last but not least of
course we have a lots of sessions for
you to explore here at the Google i/o
it's a great opportunity for you to meet
us for us to meet you so that we can
together create a more friendly and more
accessible and inclusive ecosystem thank
you for coming here today
[Applause]
[Music]